this cult of liberalism has replaced
Church of Mayor Bill DeBlasio in New
York who I think is still the mayor the
governor of New York threatened to
remove him from office because he's
doing such a bad job in in Manhattan
right now Mayor Bill de Blasio was asked
a question at a press conference that
gets right to the heart of my thesis
here he was asked why he won't let
people go to religious services because
of coronavirus remember that there was
this virus that they told us was really
bad and we couldn't go out but now it's
rioters it's fine
they said why won't you let people go to
church and synagogue but you will let
them go out and loot Fifth Avenue and
mob everybody and riot obviously there's
much more social distancing at church
than there is in these riots and de
Blasio's answer was that these riots
these call it a race riot you've got a
riot for justice you could call it
looting or you can call it a liberal
riot
you know the liberalism riot he says
that's much more important than going to
church this is the other piece of the
equation when you see a nation entire
nation simultaneously grappling with an
extraordinary crisis seated in 400 years
of American racism I'm sorry that is not
the same question as the understandably
aggrieved store owner or the devout
religious person who wants to go back to
services when you see somebody who's
been aggrieved by 400 years of slavery
that's much much more important than
people who want to go to church but
don't forget a lot of the people showing
up to these protests so-called are white
people so even if even if de Blasio is
right that nothing has changed since
slave days it's just as bad now as it
was in 1859 in the antebellum South for
black people even if that were true and
it's obviously not true but even if it
were true why are the little pasty white
and Tifa kids allowed to go there not
aggrieved by slavery they did not have
any ancestors who were slaves their
ancestors weren't brought over on slave
ships they weren't their ancestors
weren't segregated against by Jim Crow
or
lining or any of those things that
you're talking about so why do they get
to go because it's not actually not a
race thing here it's an ideological
point that Bill de Blasio's maybe
[Music]
you
[Music]